yes sir
what's up everybody Welcome to my show
12 talks and we're about to get right
into business once everybody start
loading in so stay tuned yeah we gotta
got a good screen today for y'all all
right so the first thing we gotta go
over is what Urban Meyer said to coach
Prime what it was last week I think uh
he was sent to uh to whoever he was
talking to I forgot he was talking to
but yeah he he said to him he said uh he
hired a really good coach I saw a very
good team I saw talented players his son
is an excellent quarterback what you
should doing my quarterback I'm not
being good
so yeah
I got a great quarterback back there
blowing me the ball
and then he said on me I remind him of a
player they used to have this person
Harvest which is
a good player he told Coach Tom that I
don't need to practice much longer but
for me to stay in the groove I gotta
practice I gotta be focused gotta be
ready always gotta just be ready to go
you never know what's gonna happen
number one know when you get ready so
I just like to be ready thank you very
much for what you're saying to me but
said about me but yeah I gotta practice
notice sometimes you gotta save your
legs but that's what we got treatment
for
and yeah Tio
you're a really good guy he pulled up
the practice what a week ago
and yeah that was good that was a good
practice I mean good but a couple days
that he was there he taught us a lot
talk to us just like man to man not even
about football just teaching us love
pointers and stuff
about life being a good man
uh football he told us
great things that we could take into the
game
uh what else
it was just good having a Hall of Fame
out there teaching us teaching us a lot
of things that we
got to take it to this week coming up
but yeah he was
he was on us let us know he let us know
we asked some certain questions about
the lead how is it
it was great though I like Tio
all right here is when we got in a
little scoffer in practice I think I was
on office this day too but yeah I'm not
getting this girlfriend practice
but yeah what coach Tom's trying to say
here is
the one person in our team fight we all
going down with them we always gotta
have your brothers back no matter what
and the meaning behind that is just like
that's just being just being feeling
secure with our with our team that's
that's just going to war with our teams
we're going to war together
in one fight we all fight you understand
that I don't want to see y'all walking
off with somebody's fight yes sir never
again
basically he's saying like like with one
fight we all got to go down with them we
can't just have one of our brothers out
there fighting the whole team by
ourselves everybody got to have each
other back it's just basically telling
us we got to have each other back no
matter where we are what are we doing
you just always gotta look out for your
brother that'll let you know that you
got great group of guys around you're
not telling us to go out there and just
start a fight if fights break out and
they happen to be one of us we all got
to go down with them I mean I'm trying
to remember what what they want to
affect this conference I don't remember
you remember them winning anything I
don't remember them winning anything
all right appreciate it not a big
reaction
that's a very good guy he recruited me
out Georgia when he was there so I I
like them but what he says like we still
got to prove our stuff just because we
got a lot of guys this don't mean
anything we still got a lot to prove to
people I mean he just can't be like oh
yeah we're afraid of them because they
got a lot of players now we like you
said we didn't win anything so right now
we're the underdog and we got to take
over no matter what they say look at my
cat
mm-hmm but yeah we just got to go out
there and then show them that eat their
words we just basically got to make them
eat their words really we can't
can't pick out him he's not saying
anything bad he just saying like we
didn't win anything so it's like yeah we
know we win anything but we coming
this is a Big Ten Mile right
these PL these teams are so far and we
got to go to Oregon this year look out
for like this
don't look far I ain't never been there
before that was my one of the one of the
schools I like to go I wanted to go to
when I was younger but nah dang my
school but yeah organ is far it's cold
no it's gonna be it probably not gonna
be cool when we go there but it's cool
and I know you see Colorado it's
literally a box
that's what we look like
all right what people send in the chat
yeah yeah always level-headed man some
things people say can't let get to you
you just gotta be more focused on what
you got going on not what other people
got going on what they saying to you if
you focus on that then you you're not
doing something right
yeah I'm a very chill guy see my room
ain't nothing there but uh a lot of game
and stuff if you can look at my you
can't see my desk but yeah Uncle Travis
will listen bro I'm not an uncle I'm
only 20 years old man
I just talk like a manga because I just
I'm very humble that's all I said
God bless me and be humble okay now I
hear this segment is the pick six
this is my top six teams can't judge
about my top 16s I mean this who I think
will be a good candidate for the top six
teams I mean if I'm wrong I'm wrong
but yeah
uh
my top you put it up there
uh pick number six for me is Ohio State
I think they got they got Martin
Harrison back you know very good athlete
very good receiver so I know he gonna
have that dog in them every game I've
been watching them since she's been in
college I mean he a good good player so
I think our highest Ohio state would be
up there
sooner or later
that's my pick for number six and my
number my number five pick would be LSU
I mean
they had a very good year uh last year
and they got a player on there which I
played in the under an All-American Game
he is good he is that guy and he is who
they say he is his name is perk well I
call him perk yeah it's per keyword
number four this year make sure I look
out for him make sure I stay tuned for
him because he's a good player
and number four Tennessee
have very good year last year I mean not
to what they expected well
they they felt a little short but they
got good quarterback got an arm on him
I've seen him play the last game when
the quarterback got hurt a good
quarterback no his reads know what's
going on I think they got a couple good
players and also my teammate from high
school go there his name is Ethan Davis
Titan yeah Tennessee number four number
three
I say Georgia
defending national two-time champs I
mean it's hard to beat them no matter
who you is no matter what players you
got they just play fast they disciplined
they know what's going on very good team
and Kirby Smart
he recruited me when I was in high
school very nice guy I mean I wish I
could still talk to him but I can't
he's a great coach he's just a great guy
outside of football
and number two Alabama
is always in the conversation because
they just the coach by the one of the
best Nick Saban I mean I met him before
I didn't really get to talk to him
during my recruitment because I was so
locked in
but Alabama good team I feel like
they're
make a run get people run for their
money this year even though they lost
the quarterback and number one
can't be nobody better than Colorado
coach Farm give us a lot of wisdom he
came in there and just I feel like the
players around just got the memo about
we gotta win now all the players we got
the memo we gotta it's time we got a lot
of people watching us in the world I
mean I just looked at the tickets of the
game some of the tickets is like seven
thousand dollars in life who spent that
much money to come see us play but I
guess we got one of the best fan bases
in the building
and school bus we will be at the number
one spot later in this year
bam Over Georgia
nah I don't know that's
the teams now I don't know what to do
I don't know what to say
UGA fans butt hurt because real ones
hey man I don't know what to say
no
Michigan fans punching the air
please get off
too slow
I don't like to guess I don't like the
predict who's gonna be at the top man we
don't know what God got planned for us
I just
I just hope we at the top I just hope we
do what we had to do
Michigan lucky forgot about Michigan
[Music]
thoughts on TCU
uh then we got that later on the show
let me see first
yeah we got that later in the show I'll
let you know about that later yeah Jimmy
Martin is that dude in fact but we got
hey
we got some dogs on our team people just
don't understand you know we show a lot
but we don't show a lot just because
we're trying to protect the players and
we don't want the teams know what we got
playing or what we got going on
for you
okay
oh yeah coach Farm
Ville the the new Colorado Prime Nike DT
dt96 cleats
hey these right here
I told him I need my percentage
these cleats right here just like
and nice
go pair you can't find no cleat that
look better than this just a nice
looking cleat feel good
play good
that's really not a blur but I guess I
would say that's a blur it's just me
doing what I do best High Point the ball
just doing what I do best man that's
what I like to do I like to go out then
just be able to do what I do best I mean
it's a blessing for me to have my
athleticism to be explosive how I'm an
explosive
it just I love it man but yeah that's a
blur
to make sure y'all stay tuned
for this year because it's gonna be a
very good year
Kayla wins
off of school now that's a blur that's
what you can call a blur
but yeah that's a nice that's a nice
play right there I mean
if I was the other team San Jose State
I'll be saying uh that was that it
wasn't in the plan that's uh we let him
get away with one but uh he got the ball
off and he found a receiver downfield
which receive was supposed to be trying
to be open no matter what not looking in
the backfield what looking in the
backfield to get open but yeah that's a
good play by Kayla Williams getting the
ball out to one of his guys
next
all right I haven't seen this good
for tomorrow
wait what about the ref even lost I'm
lost
huh
[Music]
they really kicked the ball Zero yards
now boy that's a blur
are you kick the ball Zero yards
he hit the ball up and then they just
went straight to the sideline it was
windy couldn't be windy I don't know
what happened but that yeah
the bar just went literally nowhere
I seen this on Instagram what yesterday
yeah they did him like the The Longest
Yard
when Addison threw the ball at the rough
because he was cheating yeah
oh no that's a blur
but yeah
that is crazy I don't know how you throw
the ball at the rough I mean I guess
you're trying to get into the receipts
oh he did get face mask too yeah
I don't know what's going on
wee
oh this game yeah gotta build a dream I
gotta build a Dream Team all-time kind
of football team I gotta build a Dream
Team basically
how many dollars like twelve dollars
it's crazy
I can't even I'm picking my coach though
so
hey I'm gonna tell y'all
coach promise first we never call him
Deion Sanders that's just disrespectful
dang I got seven dollars left
ah
gentlemen's yeah as a quarterback boy
that would be crazy yeah I'm gonna take
gentleman's ass quarterback need that
dollar
uh
that's still by the way
um I got six dollars left
so I can go five and go one again
actually actually take uh General
Manziel back take a gentlemenzel back
let me get uh Tim Tebow
let me get Tim Tebow
see it I need two dollars all I need is
two dollars
yeah see look
Dez Bryant and just Damian Kelly
easy easy word
you can't tell me that's not a good
statement client is coming off that come
here
there's my head top
Tim Tebow don't want dots running them
up everything and I got Coach Brown
right there come on man lockdown defense
offense is crazy
now we get
what's my favorite helmet uh right now
um in between the speed flex and the F7
on those with my favorite I mean my
speed Flex is a nice F7 look better
a few places good too
like a person that two dollars
who was y'all with a pick right there
that list that I mean I'm gonna make
somebody mad and I can't make my coach
man because he gotta play me
so yeah
Jefferson and Granny
ah
why did I get alert to some I'll never
oh no
Tebow over cam is crazy about 10 people
was like that though
yes
and Tebow was lighting that because Cam
Newton was like that too though
oh no man it's just some
man it's kind of hard on me man
okay shout out bro
it's not moving fast
I don't know
what another team would you want to go
to I mean my favorite NFL team is 49ers
but if I had to say I like staying in
Colorado
my girlfriend favorite team is uh not
Pittsburgh I'm tripping Green Bay
Packers everybody that I've talked to
Sam will go to Green Bay I don't know
why but Green Bay is cold
I don't got a problem with it the uh
gold but that ain't
why I gotta go to Green Bay
thank you I will do my thing this year
score prediction against TCU I don't
like to do predictions man whatever
happens happen
I want nobody to come out here back
backlashing me on another backlash
we got Joey B the only QB answer nah
there's a lot of good keys on there yes
I do play 2K
I can't wait for the new to get to come
out
favorite part
my favorite part about uh coach probably
being my coach is you can learn a lot
teach you about different things it
ain't only about football like I think a
couple days ago I went in his lock I'm
one of his office and we just sat there
and talked for like two hours
just literally two hours sitting there
talking
I mean you can you can learn a lot from
just going in there talking to them I
mean he's always there no matter what if
you need him to do so you need him for
something you got a lot of connects so
it doesn't matter whatever you need he's
there so that's what I like the most I
mean he teaches me a lot on the field
every day he teaches me something
different something that I didn't do the
day before some that he didn't see that
before then because it's always good
learning from them I mean
great dude and I know
he got a lot of connections to the NFL
I mean as long as I do my part he's
gonna do his part so just gotta believe
he said why is it disrespectful to call
Coach coach from by his real name I mean
that's just stuff you don't call no
coach by their real name you call him
it's coach first and then what they want
to be called for you don't call him
because it's like calling your teacher
by first name or his first name
disrespectful
thank you
uh
yeah I'm ready for the noise man I know
it's gonna be a lot of noise coming up I
mean
don't worry about it
yeah cause problem is all about the
program man a lot of guys there love
working with the people up there man
I love the program too
it's fun being a part of this
so I got mini chips under my bed that's
one of the snack pack
so that's what my snack set
now coach trying to only care about
yourself man if you ask the players on
the team they will they will let you
know
because this is a lot coach Mark could
teach about baseball I ain't gonna lie I
know I'll be trash for baseball one
thing I could do is run around steal
bases and catch the ball that's about it
I can't hit it
happening too fast
but anyways
we got a diff we got some coming up and
it's the Heisman segment
highs man loading
what kid what can we get I'm tripping we
can get to the hospital bring this right
about now
coming in at number four
Bo next I believe Monique's gonna be
that guy
at Oregon he's gonna be the torch for
Oregon to go as far as they want to go
and yeah I feel like Bo Nick's gonna be
that guy number three Caleb Williams
now I'm gonna say that because y'all
just seen this game this coming out
weekend hey he's what they what they've
been wanting he's that guy he's
off the above I mean he go out there
work hard I can tell you work hard he
know what to read he know when to get
out the pocket he know when to stay in
the pocket he he just made good
decisions and I mean that's what you
need at the quarterback spot
and number two shador Sanders my
quarterback
that boy good
y'all are going to see this year coming
up he can read he can a lot of people
just don't know he can get out that
pocket and move now he ain't just no
pocket fast he made great decisions he
know when to get the ball out of his
hands
you know he knows what's going on and
when they get that ball to who he need
to get that ball to what's right Tommy
you know how to get the ball to his
Playmakers and let them go to work and
number one
come on man
there's only one choice and that's me
both sides of the ball I'm going for it
all
gots to sophomore year like I said on
Instagram Heisman loaded that's my goal
that's some region you guys sometimes
you got a picture goals out there let
everybody know what you're reaching
I mean I'm just gonna do what I could do
best this year show everybody that me
going to Jackson State and so-called not
playing in a good conference
wasn't good for me I'm gonna show y'all
I'm gonna show the doubters and prove
them wrong
man we got a lot to come this season
just like I said Shadow you know what
he's doing back there and I just gotta
do my part on defense and we're gonna
take this team before as long as we
we're gonna take this team far as long
as we do what we say we're going to do
do what we are here to do and that's
when so yeah
three and a half wins this year so it's
disrespectful I mean
bro they're not going out there playing
they're not coming to our practice and
seeing what we got they're just people
looking from the outside in just talking
like everybody else that doesn't bother
us that doesn't phase me hey man I'm
just here I let everybody talk do what
they're talking so our job is to go out
there and shut everybody up so that's
what we're gonna do and that's all
that's that's how you make people regret
what they're saying that's how I make
people eat their words
me going Marcus and Harrison Jr would be
a good uh matchup fun matchup yeah I
will be I wish I was able to guard them
I mean we probably could make something
happen in the summer I mean him giving
me good work me giving him good work I
mean that ain't doing nothing but making
us better for the next stage
and that's what I'm all about I'm all
about being better getting better
focused locked in me going against the
best receiver and college football uh in
college football on the other side isn't
it I mean that's a blessing if I can get
that to make if I can make that happen
30 wins the ceiling hey man y'all see
what y'all say y'all I mean it's a lot
of none football players out there
seeing our record I mean can't get to us
with that
Playstation Xbox PlayStation oh two
PlayStations PC
yeah see back in the bed
yeah PlayStation guy always will be
Hama like in Colorado I mean
hey I love Colorado man people are nice
out here just let us this is laid back
and chill you don't got to worry about
anything
and the fans is crazy
what's the what position do I prefer to
play in the NFL hey whoever got that
number one pick and they need a receiver
corner
hey whatever they pick me up ass that's
what I'm going to ask
and I know in the league Corners make a
lot of money
uh receivers are kind of going down but
I mean whatever they pick me as I'll be
happy more than glad to go to that's
that team
oh
all right so for the head to the game
this week Saturday
Colorado
versus TCU
number 17 10 team the national champ run
UPS had a good year last year lost a lot
of guys
I mean
it depends on
how we come out how they come out we've
got the most energy who players are
willing to complete uh compete to the
end I mean where I know I'm ready my
teammate is ready everybody this has
been a long time waiting I remember
going in or transferring to Colorado
instead of 200 some days on there
talking about some of my first game I
mean we've been waiting for this for a
long time we had a great fall Camp I had
a great fall Camp team had a great fall
Camp off with one some days defense won
some days a lot of stuff y'all gonna see
it's because we are keeping that in to
our group our family we're gonna show
the world what we can do how we doing it
and we're gonna show the people in the
Dollar's room we're gonna prove them
wrong I mean
everybody saying TCU is 21.5 uh 21 and a
half Point favorite hey man
they lose
hey
I don't know what to tell y'all
if we win hey I'm just gonna go about
the next week it's next game
why didn't I go to FSU because coach
prom
I mean I want to play for
a goat he got see the same color as my
belt I mean my bear is the same color as
the jacket he got and that's what I'm
chasing I mean I believe he could teach
me a lot of things that a lot of coaches
couldn't teach me
and he's done it before so I'd rather go
play for a coach that's done it before
that could teach me a lot of things
invest in me the right the right way so
yeah
yes sir I appreciate it I will do my
thing I mean whatever God got for me I'm
gonna achieve what I could achieve now
hey appreciate y'all staying tuned
standing to the
to the screen I will be back next Monday
after the game I think same time if not
I'll give you an update on my Instagram
at db3
underscore trp Leisure report we all
give y'all another update uh when we go
live again thank you all for being here
with me I appreciate y'all see y'all
after the game Saturday and it's Travis
Hunter with 12 talks and we out
foreign